Come direct with disagreement.
The only show on the Internet you can trust.
I'm your host,
a sexy genius,
and I've spent the day memorizing poetry because of this scenes from goodwill
hunting.
It's a matter of fact,
I won't because would drastically underestimates the impact social do it
drastically underestimates the impact of social distinctions predicated upon
wealth,
especially inherited wealth.
Yeah,
you got that from Vegas Work in Essex County,
page 98 right,
because Matt Damon is a brilliant mathematician.
He is apparently memorized entire history textbooks right down to the page
number of certain important quotes.
Hence,
yeah,
I figure if memorizing history textbooks makes you a good mathematician,
memorizing romantic poetry will probably help me figure out how to escape from
this youtube bunker.
I've locked myself in.
That logic follows,
right?
I'm getting a little desperate,
so let's just get right to discussing all the weird assumptions Hollywood makes
about smart people.
It is a melancholy truth that even great men have poor relations.
Dickens.
Oh No.
I know how much he might say with irony.
I say with conviction,
what a piece of work is,
ma'am.
I get what they're going for here.
If your brain has all this extra space,
you may as well fill it with expensive sounding words,
right?
But the ability to repeat things other people wrote down,
it doesn't necessarily mean you're smart.
Think of all your friends who can recite bill Pullman speech from Independence
Day.
We will not go quietly into the night,
which is actually pretty close to what's happening in this famous scene from
tune stone.
First Doc holiday's like Vino Veritas.
Then real quick ring goes all,
ah gee quote Agis and then holiday gives him a look,
takes his time and says credit Jew dies.
Pella non ego.
Gonna ego takes a second.
Then you've [inaudible] magister and then holidays all in pouches.
Scott,
that's not a conversation.
[inaudible] goes is semi antisemetic line from one of horses.
Satires that means let the Jew a Pella,
believe it not I holiday says you have a dental.
Mr Ringu was an educator.
Yeah,
no,
I really hate them,
but really they're just throwing semi relevant famous quotes at each other like
a couple of 19th century Jake Peralta's welcome to the party pal.
Decides what kind of loser would spend all his time memorizing lines from his
favorite.
Well,
this is a little bit different,
but you know,
whenever a genius movie character quickly solves a Rubik's cube,
busy cake solving the cube isn't an insane feet.
Anyone can do it.
Provided they read the instruction manual that comes with every Rubik's cube.
It's a party trick like knowing Origami,
you're quoting Dr Strange love.
Oh,
and I decided after very little research,
this phenomenon can be traced back to Jay Robert Oppenheimer who reacted to the
first ever successful nuclear bomb tests by remembering a quote from Hindi
script.
Sure,
no,
I am the world,
but didn't actually say it.
He just remembered it because if he hadn't really responded to the first ever
nuclear explosion with I am becoming death destroyer of worlds,
everyone would have been like sort of Julius the j theJ and j Robert Oppenheimer
stands for Julius.
Was that clear without me explaining it?
Here's an incomplete list of smart characters that are also huge dicks.
You got your Dr. House,
you're Tony Stark,
you're John Nash from a Beautiful Mind.
Mark Zuckerberg from social network and re Higgins from my fair lady Nathan from
x Makena Caleb from x Mokena ava from x Mokena eventually Sherlock Holmes,
Sherlock Holmes,
Alan Turing,
Julian Assange,
Dr Stephen.
Strange con.
Wait,
how many benedict Cumberbatch is that we had here who?
Bacha Cumberbatch.
No,
that was terrible.
I should have learned how to edit so I can cut that out.
In real life.
You can be a genius and cool to people.
It's true.
I've seen it happen.
In fact,
the tendency is toward the opposite of this.
The smarter you are,
the more aware you are of your own shortcomings and the knowledge that you don't
have.
It's dumb.
People who tend to be cocky and overestimating their own intelligence.
This is called the dunning Kruger effect.
The people who think they're wicked smart or actually we can dump,
for example,
see men explaining jokes to women on Twitter.
Most of Reddit or the people correcting my abridged definition of the dunning
Kruger effect in the comments below.
Now I know about you.
I understand that there really have been smart people in the world who were also
Dick's,
but the infatuation with them that movies seem to have is still pretty baffling.
To me.
It's like we think the best part of being smart would be not having to tolerate
other people anymore,
which like life hack.
You don't have to be smart to be addicted people you can be dumb and mean.
That's just some information for you to chew on.
Batch of Cumberbatch,
you're better than this.
Surgeon movies really like to show us smart people writing on glass.
I don't have much to say about this other than it's weird.
Our smart people too distracted by their own genius to keep a note pad around.
Scraps of paper are everywhere.
I have one here and I'm going to be trapped in an underground bunker with a
bunch of DVDs and some camera equipment.
I'm living off of Stu and re fried beans and even I know where the damn notepad
is.
That's all.
Oh Gee,
I just thought of something clever.
I should write it down.
When did you become an expert in thermo nuclear astrophysics last night?
Well,
Tony Stark needs to build something.
We always see it happen because Robert Downey Jr looks great with his shirt off,
especially for a 52 year old man.
Wow.
That they do good,
Bob.
Oh,
Bob and I are friends,
which is why I get to call him Baba,
but there's nothing sexy about working your brain muscles.
So movies just skip that part and make brilliant ideas seem like they pop up
with no warning like Boehner sometimes.
Well,
each of his messages begins with the same five letters.
C I.
L.
Y.
So I suspect that city must be the name of fizzy.
More possible the gyms are instructed to use five randomness is at the start of
every message.
Well,
this blood doesn't love,
will make a band do strange things as part of this case.
I've just lost Germany.
The whole bloody walked.
What does that,
what's a matter of a deal?
We will go for the blind,
the block each other.
Not a single one of us just going to get her.
We love this idea so much that we write it into true stories.
Alan Turing didn't crack the German codes because if it's something a girl said
in a bar,
it would have been illegal for her to discuss her decoded transmissions with him
at all,
and John Nash didn't invent the Nash equilibrium because of a pretty blonde,
because that's not even how the Nash equilibrium works.
Wait a minute.
Matthew Goode was an imitation game and he was also in watchman where he played
Ozzy man dayas.
You sometimes quoted Percy Shelley who wrote epit sub Kinney and which sounds
like epiphany.
Epiphany is do what happen in real life,
but this is still part of Hollywood's weird aversion to showing us characters
who actually work for a living.
But Tony Stark ever.
Then the board meeting,
that man sleeps through his Indiana Jones,
sneaks out of his office window to avoid grading even a single paper and those
people that are all geniuses.
I'm not saying we have to have a 45 minute scene where Indiana Jones gets in
trouble with tenure review,
but it's kind of weird how much we idolize laziness,
American culture as his major heart on for pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps and paying your dues,
but all are really brilliant aspirational heroes.
Never do any of that.
These smart arms that are controlled by my brain through a neural lik nano wires
feed directly into my cerebellum allowing me to use these arms to control fusion
reaction in an environment no human hand could enter.
Quick question,
Doctor Octopus,
are you a physicist or on the neurologist or a roboticist because you just
casually described incredible breakthroughs in all of those fields and you know
what?
It's not fair for me to use the super villain,
but stick to normies like Lucius Fox from Batman who not only knows how to
design and build the train system,
but also how to run a multinational Super Corporation and cure fear toxin,
but fine.
Again,
I get it.
We're still in superhero movies.
Dr Elizabeth Straw from Prometheus's,
an archeologist and astronauts and feels comfortable performing an autopsy on an
alien head.
Those are three very specific skills that require a lifetime of study and the
third one isn't even a thing and bringing back will hunting.
He's not just a great mathematician.
He memorizes textbooks already said that it is a total expert in the probably
made up feel the reading people's minds based on their paintings.
Maybe you married the wrong woman,
maybe you should watch your mouth and this is a problem that has bled over into
the real world.
Bill Nye,
the science guy isn't an expert in all of science,
but we treat them like an expert in climate change because he has science in his
middle name.
I mean I agree with them,
but we may as well be getting a take from Dennis Quaid and see at least played a
climate change expert in a movie,
which is why real climate experts have issues with what he says.
Also,
you know,
Stephen Hawking occasionally predicts of the end of the world.
That's fine,
but it has nothing to do a theoretical physics,
which is his area of expertise.
Science is actually like a whole bunch of different things.
It's really,
well,
it was treated by this cartoon by Professor Matt and Mike,
which shows a circle containing all of human knowledge and she was a phd as a
tiny little red dick poking out toward the rent,
which by the way,
vindicates the entire point of my show because we've conclusively proven the
movies are screwing with our heads and making us dumber.
So this isn't just a bunch of pointless observations.
These are real problems.
I'm doing important work here.
We all are together.
Let's finish up.
There's the,
there's a title.
Have you read it?
Is it long enough?
Great.
Cool.
I'm not really worried about smart people.
They're going to be fine.
If anything,
they're probably in on it.
Trying to fool us,
make it harder for us to know what's really going on so they can stay.
One step ahead.
I God,
what are the smart people hiding?
Oh,
well it's probably boring.
I mean,
they're just a bunch of nerds.
Anyway.
Dammit.
Thanks for watching.
Our video,
hit the sea in the middle to subscribe at the belt,
the bottom be notified and we put up a new video.
And for those of you who stuck around and then a traveler from an anti planned
who said too vast and trunk,
less legs of stone stand in the desert near them on the sand.